sur un bon joueur alors quels sont les
enjeux de ce nouveau conseil de défense
et bien que tamyras les enjeux ou en
tout cas le sujet principal de ce
nouveau conseil de défense c'est bien
entendu le à déconfinement comment
aborder ce deuxième déconfinement de
l'année et bien d'après les premières
informations que l'on a ce pourrait être
un confinement progressif à une option
envisagée en tout cas par l'exécutif
c'est à dire est que des mesures de
restrictions vont continuer à perdurer
on parle même d'un retour du couvre feu
un autre sujet qui devrait être abordé
lors de ce conseil de défense c'est bien
sûr l'avenir des commerçants vous le
savez ils sont fermés depuis maintenant
plus de trois semaines
ils attendent avec impatience
injustement une date de réouverture une
date qui pourrait intervenir la semaine
prochaine ou en tout cas la semaine du
1er décembre en tout cas le porte-parole
du gouvernement gabriel attal a promis
une réponse à ce sujet alors de la
semaine prochaine un autre sujet un bien
sûr qui concerne les restaurants les
cafés et les bars pour à tête ont
revanche un petit peu plus compliqué
pour eux une réouverture n'est pas
envisagée tout de suite une couverture
et qui pourrait avoir lieu d'ici la
mi-janvier en attendant le gouvernement
prévoirait une aide financière pour
aider ce secteur mis à mal on rappelle
que les restaurants et les cafés ainsi
que les bars auront été fermé à auxerre
de l'année et puis une question bien sûr
qui est sur toutes les lèvres celle des
fêtes de noël pourra-t-on fêter noël en
famille le gouvernement penche bien
entendu sur ce
sujet une dérogation provisoire et
temporaire pour être accordée aux
français pour leur permettre de rendre
visite à leur famille lors de ces fêtes
de fin d'année voilà des questions
auxquelles vont plancher va plancher le
conseil de défense et des questions
auxquelles devra répondre le président
de la république ce sera en tout cas la
semaine prochaine lors d'une nouvelle
allocution du chef de l'état merci
pierre pour toutes ces précisions vous
retrouve certainement lors de nos
prochaines éditions